[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARMAN RYE: Hi there.
My name is Arman Rye, and
I'm a networking specialist
at Google Cloud.
In recent years, there have
been record-breaking numbers
of DDoS, distributed
denial of service,
attacks against organizations
and networks of many sizes,
costing companies major
financial losses, drops
in production, and
security threats.
As adversaries continue to
expand their capabilities
and frequency of
attacks, any organization
hosting a web service
via the public internet
is susceptible to attack.
While it isn't realistic
to prevent all attacks,
it's essential to mitigate
the impact when it happens.
Cloud Armor is Google Cloud's
DDoS defense service and web
application firewall solution.
One of the features available
as part of Cloud Armor
is Adaptive Protection.
Adaptive Protection helps
you protect your Google Cloud
applications, websites, and
services against layer 7 DDoS
attacks, such as HTTP floods
and other high-frequency layer
7, application-level,
malicious activity.
Adaptive Protection is a
part of Cloud Armor, which
is a broader network
security service that
provides defenses against
DDoS and application attacks.
Adaptive Protection builds
machine learning models
to identify and block web
attacks on your infrastructure.
It does this by first learning
what your normal traffic
pattern looks like for each
internet-facing website
or service, which might take
an hour to a couple of days
in order to give it enough
time to train the model.
This includes several dozen
features and characteristics
of incoming requests,
for example,
the source of the
traffic or elements
of the HTTP request coming in.
Once it's done learning
the baseline traffic
patterns of a web
service, it will then
shift to actively monitoring
for layer 7 DDoS attacks.
And it continues
to learn over time,
so as the traffic patterns
of good requests change,
it adjusts its
models automatically.
If it detects an
anomalous deviation
from your normal
traffic pattern,
it will alert you on
this anomalous activity.
It then generates a signature
describing the potential attack
and generates a custom Google
Cloud Armor web application
firewall rule to
block the signature.
Now I'll show you how it works.
I've set up a simple managed
instance group sitting
in us-east-1.
It's a backend service sitting
behind a global HTTPS load
balancer.
I've also configured
a Cloud Armor security
policy with Adaptive
Protection turned on.
Using a script, I've
simulated our good,
normal traffic with a
20-request-per-second range
and left it on for one hour.
This traffic was used
for Adaptive Protection
to profile our normal
traffic pattern.
After an hour, I will simulate
malicious user traffic
to trigger Adaptive Protection's
detection in real time.
Here we are in the Google Cloud
UI on the Cloud Armor page.
This is where you manage all
of your Cloud Armor security
policies.
Listed are multiple
security policies
that I have in this project.
Clicking in on
gcp-demo-policy, you
can see a handful of
example rules are listed.
The default action
is Allow, which
means that if no
rules are triggered,
traffic will get sent to
an instance group sitting
in us-east-1.
In addition to the
handful of rules,
Adaptive Protection is enabled
for this Cloud Armor policy.
Selecting the
Targets tab, you can
see that this policy is applied
to the unmanaged-web-backend
backend service.
This is the backend
service of the load
balancer, where the
instance groups are
located for the demo.
Under the Adaptive
Protection tab,
you can see that there has
been a steady flow of traffic
to my backend instances for
the last one hour at about
22 requests per second.
This traffic is hitting
the unmanaged-web-backend,
which is what I applied my
Cloud Armor security policy to.
This security policy has
Adaptive Protection enabled,
so this traffic has now been
profiled by Adaptive Protection
to indicate a normal
traffic pattern.
In order to simulate
abnormal traffic behavior,
I created a script to send
around 2,000 HTTPS requests
per second to the public IP
address of my L7 global load
balancer that is front-ending
my us-east-1 managed instance
group on Google Cloud.
After several minutes have
passed from my script running,
I'll head back to the
Adaptive Protection tab.
Here you can see a spike in
the number of allowed requests,
from around 22 requests
per second to over 2,000
requests per second.
You can see under
Potential Attacks
that Cloud Armor has flagged
this simulated traffic
as a potential attack.
Drilling into the most
recent alert, the Signature
and Recommended Rule tells us
the confidence level of 97%
that it is an attack.
Looking into the
details, you can
see the RemoteHost IP is
listed as part of the attack
signature, and there
is a recommended rule
to update my gcp-demo-policy
security policy to protect
against this attack.
Right from here, I
can apply the rule
in preview mode
or blocking mode.
Preview mode lets you
preview the effects of a rule
without enforcing it, while
blocking mode enforces the rule
and starts blocking
traffic right away.
The attack confidence
and recommended rule
will dictate whether you
should deploy in a preview
or blocking mode and varies
from application to application.
I'm going to select
preview mode.
Now we'll head back to my
existing Cloud Armor policy.
Here you can see a new
rule with priority 59
has been created
in a preview mode
within minutes of the
attack being kicked off.
When a DDoS attack happens,
it's a race against the clock
to minimize any damage.
Cloud Armor's Adaptive
Protection drastically
reduces the time that
incident responders
have to spend performing
analysis and proposing
mitigations to block
the ongoing attack.
You get actionable
insights right away
via machine learning-powered
analysis, pattern detection,
and recommended mitigations.
Adaptive Protection is part
of the Cloud Armor Managed
Protection Plus subscription.
The subscription also includes
a number of other security
features, like named IP
lists, DDoS response support,
and DDoS bill protection.
You can subscribe to Cloud
Armor Managed Protection Plus
in the Google Cloud Console.
And check out the links below
for more information on Cloud
Armor and how to get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]